all right royal yes sir roy oh where'd
you grow up where you're from originally
well i was born in tupelo mississippi
but i grew up in detroit michigan
detroit and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents as
this kid well it started like yeah i
didn't have either one of my parents
really uh i was born in the penitentiary
from a prostitute mom she was 16.
my daddy was a truck driver he was 20.
and uh
my mom got they released me to my
grandmother uh mary jane
my dad uh
my dad was in and out of prison he's one
of the biggest meth cooks in uh in the
south
anyway uh so
when i was uh 30 years old
i had my own kid
he got taken from me
and that's when my dad told me the story
about when i was six months old
sorry just think about my kid
when i was six months old that uh he had
to get me back too you know blah blah
blah
anyway
sorry bro
you're not the only one
anyway
so
uh my mom sold me to some bad people
when i was six months old and uh billy
my dad
he was a part of a
you know
let's just call them the dixie anyway
they went down to florida and they got
me back and then
you say your mom sold you yeah yeah for
what cocaine
sold you as a child as a as a baby six
months old she didn't want nothing doing
me you know wow and so uh then uh
you know i didn't find this out until i
was like 30 like i said
so billy said uh you know and he was
like well your dad your dad got you back
yeah and uh on the way back out of
florida right before he got onto the
georgia line there uh he said he looked
over at these apartment complexes and
seen my granddaddy's chevelle sitting
there
so he knocked on all the doors of the
apartments until finally carried come to
the door
and that time i guess he blasted her in
the mouth and threw her in the back of
the 18-wheeler
and then took her to alabama and sold it
to a motorcycle game
which i'll just leave that that out the
name of the gang out you know
after that uh
i got went back to mary jane my
grandmother and my grandfather mark
which they were great people uh
they did a real good job but
it was mississippi you know so
they didn't really go through all the
legal
mamma jamma of like getting custody and
their names or whatnot so
when i was eleven oh and i had my mom
had had another kid by then too
harley
she was five so when i was eleven harley
was five carrie showed back up one night
on the back of a harley davidson
and uh
she said she wanted us back so
my grandmother didn't have no choice but
to give us back to her
and then the next day
she put us on a plane and we moved to
detroit michigan and that's
you want to talk about culture shock you
take a
11 year old kid like i done started
smoking pot for the first time by that
time you know and everything
and then you move them to the city and
it was just wild
about [ __ ] four months after living
there uh kerry shot me up with heroin
for the first time
uh
and then it just was it was just a big
mess after that i got involved with uh
with a street gang
and it's pretty much uh
it was the the best thing that happened
to me really
because they got me away from the house
you know
and then uh
when we got there they knocked on the
door
and they said we seen you have a boy
with you and my mama was like yeah
and they're like well you're either
gonna pay us or he's with us
you know what i mean so i didn't have no
choice
so then when i got in there and i told
them how my life was at home and [ __ ]
they told me i didn't have to go back
and i was like my little sister
they said don't worry we'll take care of
that your mama won't touch your sister
because carrie was real abusive man she
she only knew
i'm not trying to like stand up for her
at all
she only knew what had been done to her
in the biker game on how to show love
you know this is your mom you're talking
about yeah so she thought by making me
eat her [ __ ]
was showing me love
you know what i mean because your mom my
mom yeah that's what
the biker games like installed on her
which uh i have
made a point in my life to like not
dwell
on that kind of thing
you know
three times i had to go into her head
and
the japanese suck at making firearms
because every time the bullet misfired
every time
and uh
so i just gave up on that you were
trying to i was trying to kill her you
know
and uh
anyway
so i graduated high school on my own
though
uh
it was something i wanted to do and then
uh
i went to college and that's where i got
my first felony
and i went to prison for the first time
what was that for
in michigan what would you do i was uh
uh sales of uh cocaine
uh over 25 grams i was uh when i man
when i was 19 i had
stacks of money in my pocket bro
it's like cocaine was a very good
selling drug you know anyway when i was
in prison uh
jack kevorkian was my
was my cell mate that's right and ken
ross michigan yeah
i only had to do like i only did like a
year
a year and like nine months because it
was my first charge but most people got
probation you know
what was kevorkian like
uh he was a real [ __ ] like
[ __ ] guy uh
constantly bitching about being locked
up and having to be in there i would
just steal all this paperwork and send
it home and get paid for it so like
he was really a benefit to me he
couldn't figure out it was me that was
doing it but like i got uh 1800 for his
identification badge
i stole it and sent it home to some
people
but uh when i was um
so when i got home from prison
the only place i knew to go was my mom
my mom's house you know
i had to parole out to there so when i
got there
i walked in the house and i was like wow
this is different you know i didn't
knock on the door or anything i just
walked in
and i was looking around man this is
really different i could hear the shower
going you know
so i just uh went to the fridge and i
opened the fridge and i was like man
this is a bunch of weird-ass beer in
here because you know they're from the
south they drank budweiser and stuff
like that and there's all these like
like just weird-looking beers you know
and i kind of was like this is really
funny like something's off you know so i
sat down at the kitchen table and smoked
me a cigarette
and i heard the shower go off in the
little room right there the bathroom was
right there but we never used that
bathroom and i thought that was weird
too and then about that time here come a
girl
out of the shower and my family had
moved from michigan to indiana
and i had no clue whatsoever so here's
this chick with the towel on her head
butt booty naked she starts screaming
and i didn't even try to go nowhere i
just went out on the back porch and
waited for the cops to get there you
know they showed up and asked me what
the problem was and i told them they
actually let me make it that day and uh
they said well you should have done like
you're supposed to do and come and
report it to the parole officer first
before you come home because then you
would have been told that your family
left and went to indiana
and so i was like [ __ ] man i called home
i called called my mama and she was all
upset like
i'm like why are you upset i just got
out of prison she said
your little sister was raped last night
by some guy at a pool hall in the town
in indiana
so uh my neighbor
he had a 68 barracuda
and i always liked that car
i like that car a lot i stole cars like
when i was in michigan that's what i did
but i'd always let him make it because
he was my neighbor you know you never
[ __ ] where you eat or sleep you know
so i was like [ __ ] it man
i walked over and i looked the keys were
in it
i fired that [ __ ] up and i went
straight to indiana man straight there
and uh
they didn't have cell phones yet you
know cell phones wasn't thin yet so
first pay phone i saw i called
i said carrie uh where was harley at and
who did it
she said julio did it and uh he was at
this pool hall
down there and i can't remember the name
of the road or what not but
there was a tire tool in the trunk of
the car so i shoved it down the back of
my pants and i had a the car had a
[ __ ] nine millimeter in it already
there was no bullets in the gun but they
didn't know that and uh so i rolled up
to the pool hall and i just
walked up to the first person i seen
going to his head and i said who's julio
and uh the dude was shooting again pool
he said i'm julio i grabbed the tire
tool out and i commenced beating his
brains out right there
right there in the spot you know i
rubbed his blood on my face and i said
indian style on the sidewalk till the
police got there
i sat in the um
gary i think it was gary county indiana
i'm not sure i sat in jail
13 months waiting on trial and i took a
judge trial instead of jury trial
and i didn't speak to anyone i didn't
have a lawyer represent me i mean there
was an open shut case you know i figured
they were going to give me the death
penalty no problem
i was actually expecting it wanting it
and uh the judge finally said well um
you know he said he used my name or
whatnot and he said you got anything to
say and i looked at him straighten the
eyes and i said well if you'd write my
little sister i'd [ __ ] killed you two
and uh he covered the microphone he said
come here
and i walked up to the desk he said
when you get back to your cell you pack
your [ __ ]
and you leave indiana and you never come
back
so i never went back to indiana
you know that was that was the first
major break in my life
from
death sentence
to uh freedom
right like that
well the uh the barracuda had been
impounded so i couldn't get it out you
know so
i didn't know i wasn't gonna live with
my mama
but i went by the house anyway
so when i got to the house once again uh
the man she had married jimmy
he was sitting there and he was all beat
up i mean he was barely alive when i got
there she had beat the [ __ ] out of him
and i asked him what happened and uh
he said uh
your mama had rocky looper
show up and uh
they went back to mississippi so rocky
looper is harley's real daddy uh
he's a big piece of [ __ ] he's dead now
so
i go
to mississippi which i didn't want to go
you know it sucks there it's horrible
they got no heroin and broken
everybody's spun out of their brains to
the max and i had tried to go a couple
years before that
like right when i first got out of high
school
before i went to prison stuff i had
drove to mississippi one day and as soon
as i got to my dad's house he was being
raided by the fbi
for manufacturing methamphetamines and
uh
making illegal porno
and so they give them 36 calendars
so there's no reason for me to go back
to mississippi you know
and then uh carrie took harley back to
mississippi so i had to go take care of
her
and when i got down there
i realized that uh there was a reason
for me to go to mississippi because i
learned how to manufacture
methamphetamines myself
and
i was good at it and
it was kind of fun and everything
and there's a couple of real bad
incidents as soon as i
i mean
as soon as i got there it was it was
hell because uh
you know rocky didn't want nothing to do
with me because i was a you know billy
shelton's son
and they had had beef before we were
ever there and billy was in prison
and uh i found out i had three other
sisters
that really had you refer to your
parents by first name oh yeah
yeah i don't hear that a lot um
you know billy's in prison again by the
way he got uh he got caught
manufacturing again
now that he's 60 years old they give him
a they can after after he got such a
break because when katrina hit
when katrina hit all right so that's
let's just jump to that
you know i'm stuck in mississippi now so
i'm like i'm gonna make the best out of
it uh i hooked up with this girl and her
dad was an electrician and he taught me
how to do electric work so then i got on
a huge job down on the coast of
mississippi biloxi
which biloxi is cool it's kind of like
vegas with sweet tea you know it's kind
of pretty cool it was more of my flavor
because you know being in detroit so
long i was like was used to hearing
stuff at night when i go to sleep or
whatever or just something going on and
tupelo there's nothing going on like
like um i went to jail
one time 36 times
in tupelo just for misdemeanors or
whatnot
and uh anyway so i got the biloxi
oh and this is this is something crazy
the street gang that i had joined in
michigan was also in mississippi i
didn't know that when i got there so
it was like i was right in the mix again
you know
anyway so
blah blah
now i'm involved in that
and
[Music]
so
i get this job working with this
electrical company and
there's six of us in the truck
we get pulled over
and they find an eight ball of crystal
meth in the toolbox
okay
of course no one claimed it well guess
what they did they charged every one of
us with a felony
so i go back to prison again two years
during that two years uh
my dad was in prison so i got to spend
uh mississippi's only got three prisons
in the whole thing so it's kind of funny
now the place i was born in
here i am living in it again
and my dad's there and he's a trustee
so i got to spend a little time with
billy
and so they let me out in
july on my birthday actually july 2005 i
got out
so um my dad was like your aunt kim has
given you a house on the coast so you
can go live on the coast you know so i
had my own place and never had my own
place before
and uh
i'm sitting there and
you know
i'm watching the weather and i'm
thinking wow new orleans looks really
cool
you know
and then uh there's this big storm come
coming in and i'm like man this is
getting kind of bad
and sure enough we got hit with a
schedule five hurricane hurricane
katrina
and it was beating the house down like
horribly so
once again my neighbor
had a vehicle that i really liked it was
a uh
there was a z71 chevrolet stinney cab
step side
and me and my friend cooter and uh
his girlfriend my girlfriend true
we jump in the truck
and uh we head to new orleans because
the weather said it was nice and
sunshiny there
showed pictures of people on bourbon
street partying or whatnot well we knew
the hurricane was coming so we stopped
at slidell louisiana
because we was almost out of gas and uh
i walked up to the register i told
cooter fill the truck up he's like we
ain't got no money i said don't worry
about it i got it
i told the guys i set a case of beer on
the register i said i need uh two packs
of new ports two packs of marlboros and
we're filling that chevrolet up out
there
so he rings it all up and when he tells
me the price i just [ __ ] him
grab the beer and cigarettes go get in
the truck we had new orleans you know
got away with it because
all the authorities knew what was gonna
happen you know
so we had this guy named bear that we
were getting drugs from like in biloxi
so we went to see bear first thing you
know and uh
he was freaking out we're like bear
what's the matter what's the matter
he's like i gotta get to my mama's house
i gotta get to my mama's house i'm like
why
he's like cause mama can't swim
i'm like what do you mean mama can't
swim we're not going to a party he's
like the levees have broken
within a matter of minutes we're going
to be overrun with water
and i'm like [ __ ] well good thing i got
four wheel drive come on let's go i'm
sorry i'm getting a little sick man like
yeah just a little bit i know anyway so
um
we get to bears mamas which was in the
ninth ward of louisiana and the water is
all the way up to the center hub of the
truck by now
and we get in the house and by the time
we get
into the house the water is coming into
the house all right
so we climb on the truck and get on the
roof of the house
and by this time the water has gone over
the truck
and we don't know what the [ __ ] we're
gonna do man we just we ain't got no
clue it just so happened that i had uh i
had a 40 caliber glock on me
and cooter had a 380 on him
which you would think like this is
nothing you know like why why are you
telling me about cause those guns is the
only reason i stayed alive
uh in california nobody carries a gun
it's kind of cool
you know
but anyway so um
we're
we're on the roof and there's uh
new orleans parish
uh police going by in boats and we're
like hey and they're just acting like
they don't see us
you know because we're a couple a bunch
of white people on the on the house on a
roof in the ninth ward you know they
don't really care you know
and so uh
finally finally
um we managed to rip some plywood
off the top of the house and the girls
that were with us were like take
shingles and put on the inside and it'll
make it where the water don't come in
and
i'm glad they thought about that because
it shone off did like
we made some makeshift uh
makeshift rafts
and we put them out in the water we seen
where the the parish because that's what
they call them instead of county sheriff
they call them parish
shares they were down a little ways so
we figure if we throw in the colonel
catches
and we'll get down to where the rescue
boats were
or whatever and uh so we're my friend
cooter is trying to catch the rope
and we left baron his mama on the roof
like he was too big to get in the boat
and she couldn't swim anyway
so
he's trying to catch the rope and when
he did he fell out
and uh as he was falling out he threw
his 380 in and his girlfriend grabbed it
and
about that time he was trying to stay up
and he couldn't stay up and i looked
over to the left and here come the
alligator
and he grabbed got cooter and grabbed
him
and
he was freaking out or whatever and my
girlfriend she was like shoot him shoot
him baby shoot him and i'm like who
shoot the alligator she's like no shoot
cooter he's getting neat by the
alligator
and i couldn't do it
i fired a shot off but all i done was
hit the alligator and that caused it to
go
underwater and take my friend down with
him and like
literally like me shooting at the
alligator got the cops attention and
then they drove their boat over
and and helped us and they just dropped
us off on the front lawn of the uh louis
armstrong park civic center
which a lot of people don't know about
that
everybody else thinks that the superdome
is where everybody went
when uh
when the hurricane happened but you know
we were we made our own shelter there
all this time by the way i'm on heroin
and uh on crystal meth like i've always
done drugs
i figure you might as well get to the
good part right um
yeah the hurricane katrina was [ __ ] up
and uh we didn't have no dope it was bad
um
in the shelter like if one person got a
biscuit and another person didn't get a
biscuit everybody would fight it was
horrible people were getting raped
the only thing like i said the only
reason that
i stayed alive and cooter's girlfriend
and my girlfriend didn't get raped was
because we had those guns
and uh
we literally uh
one day i decided the water was like
kind of going away and
like it was it was it was horrible there
i knew we were going to die there
so i got us out of there and uh we made
our way to the superdome
oh
when i was in there i was on the roof
one day
and i heard a helicopter
and i looked up
and it was uh it was uh what is it air
force one or helicopter one the
president's helicopter
george bush
and he was trying to uh
act like he didn't see us
on the roof you know because all they
had known was people were in the
superdome
so like as they flew over the top of us
he's he didn't even look down he like he
like hung out of the helicopter
and like um
one of my buddies had a 30 out six on
the roof and he was gonna
you know pull the trigger and i reached
over and put my hand in front of the
scope because i knew that wouldn't do no
good you know
and uh but sure enough he acted like
they didn't even see us there and it
took another two weeks before we ever
even got food after that you know it was
it was pretty rough
so we managed to uh we managed to fight
our way to the superdome like uh
the streets and the streets were just
chaotic you know uh
very very chaotic and uh
after we got to the superdome
we ended up getting a ride back to
mississippi and that was that you know
but uh
it was pretty tough um
my friend would probably like this joke
you know i
i usually say you know cooter got eight
you know a joke but
anyway uh i got a new uh a new uh
respect for alligators now
uh
and things like that and uh
new orleans is a
definitely a different type of place
uh
and all the places i ever lived
is definitely the
most chaotic most savage and
most
cutthroat worse in detroit it's worse
than detroit by far people from detroit
are scared to go to new orleans yeah
you know
so anyway i i decided that like it was
only right that i go live in new orleans
since my friend died there and i left i
left mississippi and i went back to new
orleans and uh
uh
i got a gun charge while i was there
this guy tried to rob me and i pissed
whipped his gold teeth out
and uh anyway so i did five years in
angola on a gun charge and the day i got
out of angola somebody told me they set
up
you see that one over that uh i-10
highway over there i said yeah i see it
they said they go straight to santa
monica california
i said really
they said yeah i went out there and i
stuck my thumb out and i never looked
back never looked back i've been in
california now since
so when i got out here
uh
you know i've been on the streets
i've been on the streets since katrina
actually uh if i wasn't in prison i was
on the streets
live on the streets is a lot different
[Music]
you know
there's a lot of stealing going on
there's a lot of
a lot of
just there's no unity
between people on the streets like if if
if a category of a natural disaster ever
happened in california like happened in
new orleans that day i would be very
frightened
to see what happened to the people out
here like it wouldn't be good
because no one knows how to stand next
to each other
and then like you know i've been here
for an earthquake
a big earthquake back in 94.
and it was pretty beautiful everybody
helped everybody else out yeah
it was pretty amazing people that never
talked to each other that's great we're
everyone was helpful
but uh so um
you know uh
anyway so um
i was in california for six years
living on the streets every day um
just doing my own thing and i went to
vegas
then i went to vegas on accident
i thought i was going to a gemstone oh
speaking of i thought i was going to the
gemstone convention
i made this for you by the way
uh
gemstone convention in phoenix uh
phoenix arizona and when i woke up we
were in vegas
and so i had to go skateboard in las
vegas and uh anyway i was there for a
year
and one day i just out of nowhere i
decided to come back and uh
when i was in vegas we were only doing
black we weren't doing fentanyl
that's one of the main reasons i left
because i was wanting to try to get
clean again
it's it's it's a horrible it's a it's a
horrible thing to be on because
it's unmanageable um you can't
like i used this morning at six a.m and
i'm already getting sick
and uh
do you need to fix right now yeah i do
want you want to i don't have anything
you don't have anything
yeah yeah yeah i need some money if i
got money how fast could you do well i
mean like i'd rather finish this you
would yes okay let's just keep going and
finish keep going you know
because uh what i'm getting at is gonna
be like you know my girlfriend's with me
so you know this is what i'm getting to
so uh
you know
i was just uh i was what i would do is
i'd wrap stones
and every girl that i thought looked
interesting you know i would just give
them a stone and like you know i don't
want nothing back it's just a little
present from the beach what not what not
so one day uh
one day i was uh just getting high uh
down
like one of the weirdest things about
california is public restrooms you know
like you never know what's going to
happen
when you're like at a public restroom on
the beach you know
and anyway so i give this girl a stone a
couple days prior
and then sure enough here she come back
down to the beach and um she was a
recovering heroin addict too
and uh she said that um
she uh wanted to try fentanyl
and i was like you really don't need to
try fentanyl let's just go to hollywood
and get some black you know you know and
on our way out we run across one of my
friends from hollywood
and he said he had some fentanyl
so we went back to my bando and you know
i let her try it or whatever i can't say
later she wanted to try it so she tried
it you know
and then she started like
picking at the carpet so i figured like
most junkies you know she was just
looking for stuff in the carpet so i
went over and started painting on my
wall because i do art now that's what i
do instead of crime i do art
and i turned around and looked and uh i
couldn't figure out
i was like where'd that girl go you know
it was like an hour later i turned
around looked and she was blue
she had done overdosed off of one hit
and didn't have any of those they call
it narcan we didn't have any narcan
we didn't have anything to bring her
back and um i just started giving her
cpr and then like
had to slap her a few times and she
ended up coming back and the first thing
she said when she come back is i want
another hit
you know
and so
she's overdosed uh
nine other times
since that
and it's like every day every day i have
to [ __ ] uh bring somebody back that's
overdosed
and
only two people
that i've ever brought back have ever
just said i don't ever want to do this
again everybody else
is wanting to reach right for the foil
and go right for the foil
and you know um
so we can't use suboxone suboxone makes
you get sicker
i just i really i really don't know
where to go from here you know
like i said i couldn't i couldn't see
myself trying to work a job
like what a like
if i get sick at work and then i'll lose
the job right away you know so i really
don't know where to go from here
i guess uh
and then there's always the chance of
getting busted you know i got i went to
jail one time in l.a before i met uh
jennifer uh when i was on fentanyl first
time and i did two weeks in jail
for a dope pipe
and uh
the only reason they made me sips
because they knew i was going to
withdraw
and it literally i was withdrawing the
whole two weeks
when i used to do heroin i could
literally just kick heroin in three days
and not have to do it anymore you know
because it's always been like a struggle
like like i said
my mom
shot me up for the first time when i was
11. and i've been on it ever since then
like
it was like oxycontin and delada mostly
back then and then uh the government got
real hard on the prescription pills
so we started doing heroin you know
and like
this
deadly struggle really i don't know
i don't know
and where do you where you live now
you're in a tent uh yeah i was in a tent
up until two days ago
and uh they got us in this thing called
project room key
which i don't know how that's gonna work
out or not you know do you have you have
housing right now right now i do but
it's the first time that i've ever
lived indoors since katrina
you know it's kind of weird you know
of course we can't use in there
so honestly we haven't even stayed in
there we've been out using it instead of
being in there
you know
how can they keep you from using and
well you're not allowed to take drugs in
you know
so
uh
you know we don't want to like
take the drugs in and like lose your
housing lose our housing you know so
you'd rather stay out and not not use
your housing
right
right
we went in last night because it was
raining but right how do you support
yourself
what's that how do you support yourself
um
well sometimes i
boost you know
but i'm not that good at it you know i
mean even though you don't have to be
good at it in la to do it um
it's
boosting is too stressful for me i'm a
panhandler
i'm a panhandler uh
you know uh i don't uh i don't really
agree with a prostitution you know
you know i don't do any uh
you know gay for pay or nothing like
that like uh i make pretty good money
panhandling believe it or not matter of
fact like something i was going to say
uh
i make so much money panhandling
sometimes that i'm afraid i might not
ever work a real job again
like for instance the black eyed peas is
in town tonight
when that concert gets out i bet you me
and my dog make at least three hundred
dollars
like the band the neighborhood played
two weeks ago we made four hundred
dollars
in an hour
just paying it a whole sign that says
hungry as [ __ ]
it's really weird really
but uh
you know
i don't know how do you know i'm uh
i was born in 84 so i think it's like 37
do you have kids i do have one kid
where is he he's in mississippi
it's hard for you to be separate
you know uh i i took that part of my
life out because uh it was really boring
you know
when i found out that i was gonna have a
baby i actually got clean
uh
first three years i didn't do no drugs i
didn't even smoke pot man
like he got me high
and then one day i was at work and uh i
got a call from my mother-in-law
and she said uh
she said amy's in jail
i said well what's amy in jail for she's
like hell i thought you could tell me
i'm like well i don't know
well she had two other kids come to find
out while i was in jail i mean while i
was at work
she had been selling her kids adderall
so that she could get xanax's
and she had sold to an undercover cop so
because of that because she was selling
her kids pills
the child protection services showed up
and took my kid from me
well come to find out amy had never made
a birth certificate on corbin so since
she was married to somebody else when
she had the baby
he got parental rights of my kid not me
and so i haven't seen my kids since that
day
and uh it's been a big ordeal well i've
seen him one time i seen him for a week
one time after that
i got a call
i got a call that she was at a house
where they were cooking meth
and i went over there and uh
i took the baby
actually i hit myself in the in the head
with a pistol that night to scare
everybody it worked it made him all run
that way i could get back to where the
baby was and get him out of there
and uh
then when i went to the police to tell
the police what had happened and that i
had my kid they took my kid from me
right there even though i had done what
was right you know and so i decided the
best thing was for me to leave
because i was going to end up getting in
a lot of trouble
so
i hope he's doing okay you know
they don't let uh
i don't talk to anybody back home
anymore so i don't know
it's a hell of a life you lived yeah
yeah what's your what's your biggest
regret
i don't have any
i don't have any
of them if i was going to have regrets i
wouldn't be able to be who i am today
regrets cause pain and pain causes
mistakes you know and i can't afford to
make a mistake
at all
you know because if i make a mistake
then something's bad could happen you
know
what's the most important thing you've
learned in your life
most important lesson
that
material possession means nothing and
that
um
that the people that
you you know when you show loyalty
you get loyalty back you know and um
you know the memories you make and the
the people that
show their loyalty back to you is what's
important you know
uh
of uh
the girl that
the girl that overdosed that day we've
been together ever since three years
we use dope every day
neither one of us is it we make a joke
we say yeah we're really interesting we
don't we don't [ __ ] around on each other
and we don't take our clothes off to get
our dope you know
everybody thinks that that's funny you
know but you know it's
it's kind of it makes it kind of kind of
a struggle sometimes because we see
other people they like got piles and
piles of dope and we're like she's like
well how are they doing so good or not
like well they break their values you
know they they don't have any
care about what they do to get their
dope you know
and
i don't know
it's it's crazy out here though
i think what you're doing is a really
good thing though
yeah it's it's it's definitely
interesting to learn the back
the story behind
all these people that are just living on
the street and you know look at you it'd
be easy to see you panhandling oh geez
why don't you just get a job
and then you hear the whole story and
you see the situation you're in today
and on fentanyl it's going to be really
hard for you to do anything
for eight hours
so i guess
i guess i could say you see and then i
don't even regret getting on fentanyl
because you don't shoot it up anymore we
don't shoot up anymore
i mean
a little bit here and there i mean the
thing is is like like i said i haven't i
used it six o'clock this morning and i
think it's like what one o'clock
i'm already drenched in sweat and i'm
like
you know
if i i wish i would have been
more see like because i was like really
pumped up for doing this story
and uh i feel like because i don't got
sick it's taken away from what i was
gonna say you know and do
and uh did a great job thank you
but uh you know it's like
it's tough you know i mean like
uh there's been a lot a lot more crazy
things happen like i could tell you
stories after stories after stories
you know but none of it really gets to
the point
you know and the the point is like
um
mothers shouldn't treat their kids like
i was treated
you know and
and
i'm lucky that like i met some of the
people i met along the way that helped
me keep my mind
where it was and not become
the person like she was because you know
they say genetics
is genetics you know
and i've made it a point to like not be
like
carrie and billy you know
which all right royal thank you so much
for sharing your
very interesting story thank you i wish
you the best of luck and thank you we'll
give you what you need right now
thank you
you